d'accord on va recevoir notre deuxième
invité may Goldman bonsoir bonsoir euh
vous savez vous connaissez vous les
gestes qui sauvent vous écoutez avec
attention j'ai assisté à des formations
que nous avons organisé dans le cadre du
CC de notre village parce que vous vous
savez vous vous savez faire battre les
cœurs c'est gentil ah oui alors on vous
on vous avait reçu il y a quelques mois
vous étiez venu présenter un très joli
livre l'amour à point d'âge où vous
parliez d'un sujet un peu tabou encore
dans la société c'est comment être
amoureux après 60 ans comment
s'autoriser le droit d'aimer voilà c'est
ça c'est ça surtout s'autoriser le droit
d'aimer et alors là vous revenez avec un
nouveau livre qui s'appelle couleur bleu
lavande c'est la couleur des yeux de
l'héroïne qui s'appelle Alexandra non
oui alors Alexandra elle a un mari elle
a un mari et et un amant et un
voilà donc chez may Goldman les femmes
ont droit de tout elles ont le droit de
multiimer elles sont elles sont libres
ouais à partir de là elles font
euh oui ou non elles ont elles ont un
amant elles n'ont pas forcément un amant
mais elles sont libres de disposer de
leur corps elles n'appartiennent pas au
mari c'est clair he c'est ça c'est très
clair et est-ce que le mari il a le
droit d'avoir des maîtresses
certainement d'accord alors le premier
livre que vous avez écrit enfin le livre
que vous aviez écrit pour lequel vous
étiez venu nous voir l'amour à pointâge
était autobiographique c'était votre
ou là ce n pas autobiographie pas du
tout non non c'est pas du tout et en
fait le premier livre il est écrit en
2009 euh oui il est paru en 2009 et j'ai
commencé couleur bleu lavande à peu près
un an après j'ai quand même mis 2 ans
pour l'écrire voilà non il n absolument
pas pas
autobiographique
mais j'ai j'ai certaines convictions
j'ai certaines opinions comme tous les
auteurs je pense et et et je pense qu'il
est aussi qu'il est inévitable qu'on
qu'on retrouve mon ressenti même si ce
n'est pas autobiographieque alors quel
est votre ressenti c'est un ressenti
féministe oui très très moi je défends
les femmes j'admire les femmes j'admire
les femmes les femmes de tous les jours
celles qui qui élèvent des enfants et
qui font un travail à côté qui font leur
courses qui font marcher la maison les
femmes qui font tourner le monde qui
font que tout fonctionne parce que ça je
crois qu'on on se rend pas suffisamment
compte mais euh ce sont les femmes qui
font tourner le monde qui il sourent lu
guiss là les femmes qui font t pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas ah bah oui personne ne
dira jamais le contraire et puis de
toute façon il vaut mieux faire battre
les cœurs naturellement et de la manière
dont on parle madame que avec un
défibrilateur c'est toujours plus oui ça
merci
beauou c'est très beau c'est très beau
alors Alexandra donc je dis elle est
elle est mariée avec Marc elle a un
amant George oui c'est quand même
compliqué pour elle c'est c'est
compliqué parce qu'elle aime Marc et
elle aime George elle aime vraiment les
deux de d'un amour très très sincère
mais ce n'est pas le même amour Marc
c'est son homme c'est son compagnon
depuis très longtemps elle est marié
avec lui et et George elle a rencontré
il y a eu un coup de foudre elle n'a pas
su dire non pas su dire non est-ce
qu'elle avait besoin de dire non ah ça
dans la mes
non mais oui dans la pensée de Mighty
Goman elle devait dire oui elle ne peut
pas dire non elle ne peut pas résister
il faut qu' libère elle est libre voilà
alors dans mon premier livre le mari ne
souffrait pas de la
situation le mari d'Alexandra il en
souffre un peu mais par amour pour
Alexandra il accepte il accepte et quand
elle réalise pour finir que ça va aller
trop loin que ça va casser son histoire
avec Marc alors que c'est l'homme de sa
vie
elle rond avec George et George il sait
aussi très bien que il ne pourrait
jamais vivre avec Alexandra donc il
décide de se quitter c'est une autre fin
que dans l'amour à pointinage mais ce
qui est beau aussi dans vos histoires
c'est que effectivement je l'ai dit ça
ce sont des femmes qui ont une j'avais
dire une grande maturité enfin c'est des
femmes âgées on peut dire ça c'est des
histoires de femmes âgées c'est rare de
parler de de l'amour comme ça après 60
ans on dit souvent ah si je pouvais
recommencer ma vie mais sachant ce que
je sais maintenant euh tomber amoureux
après ou amoureuse surout après 60 ans
en fait c'est retombé en adolescence
mais sachant ce qu'on sait maintenant et
c'est pas la même chose c'est
merveilleux mais on a quand même le cœur
qui bat hein le cœur il bat toujours et
on fait toujours les mêmes erreurs hein
non à 20 ans 40 ou 60 moi je pense qu'on
fait les mêmes erreurs h n pas les mêmes
raisonnements pas les mêmes
raisonnements non non pas du tout je je
crois qu'on sait quand même on garde
dans le cas d'Alexandra comme dans le
cas de de Julie il y a des gardes fou
qu'on n pas à 18 ans parce qu'à 18 ans
le coup de foudre c'est tout alors que
là c deux femmes qui ont respectivement
62 et 70 ans elles ont des maris elles
vont pas tout
casser de même que leur chagrin d'amour
raison c'est quand vous avez publié
Votre votre livre l'amour à point d'âge
est-ce que quelle réaction vous avez eu
du public notamment féminin est-ce que
des lectrices féminines sont venus vous
voir en disant ah vous nous donnez le
droit de peut-être le droit d'aimer vous
vous osez dire ce que nous pensons et
aussi ce que nous aimerions faire et
depuis j'ai rencontré
plusieurs plusieurs personnes ou
plusieurs couples qui vivent une
histoire comme ça où il y a
euh la femme avec le mari et l'amant euh
il y a un couple où ça se passe très
très bien où le mari le sait dans les
deux cas les mari les savent et où il
est très heureux pour sa femme où il est
très ami même avec l'amant et il y a un
autre couple où le mari le prend très
moins bien mais par amour pour sa femme
il accepte et ça existe et cétait
beaucoup plus connu pour les hommes en
fait moi je raconte que pour les femmes
ai ça existe vous Prz la position des
femmes le livre jeai pas dit est paru
tout récemment Mo on peut se procurer où
alors au pavé dans la Mar au
oui oui et puis à la librairie du centre
àp j'ai déjà fait des dédicaces dans les
deux dernières librairies j'en referai
la prochaine dédicace c'est le 29
septembre àétant la ville la ville voilà
merci beaucoup my d'être venue en
plateau merci jeanl écoutez avec
attention ou tout à fait tout à fait
tout à fait ça vous intéresse bon tout à
fait oui encore je pense que la vie
accompli à de est déjà compliqué alors à
3 6 FO on se mett beaucoup de problèmes
sur le dos parole d'homme sûr classique
réaction classique d'accord je suis
classique c'est la bataille j'assume
j'ass c'est la bataille d'accord ok ben
merci en tout cas à vousêtre venu sur ce
plateau avant de nous quitter un retour
sur les faits de l'actualité de ce jeudi
20 septembre des retards dans les
transports ce jeudi des trains supprimés
un trafic perturbé pendant toute la
matinée en cause une rupture du fil
d'alimentation pour aider et conseiller
les intérimaires il existe le Fast le
fond d'aide aux travailleurs temporaire
et pour se faire connaître cet organisme
a organisé des réunions d'information à
la Cité des Métiers de trappe pendant
cette semaine de la mobilité nous vous
proposons le portrait de cquanttinois
qui choisissent des modes de transport
alternatifs pour se rendre à leur
travail exemple avec Michel Beranger qui
lui a opté vous le voyez pour la marche
à pied c'est encore le plus simple le
petit et le grand le club de football
est en cours a signé un partenariat avec
l'AG oxer l'objectif améliorer la
formation sportive et éducative des
jeunes joueurs joueurs et pour terminer
ce 78 je vous propose donc de revenir
sur l'information principale de ce jeudi
20 septembre c'est ce retard très
important dans les transports ce jeudi
matin les usagers ont souffert à La
Verrière même certains qui ont fait
demi-tour parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
train reportage Antony reche 7h30 ce
jeudi matin une des deux voies de rerc
au niveau de la gare de 550 an en
Yveline connaît un défaut d'alimentation
un train reste bloqué la situation a
duré une partie de la matinée mais les
voyageurs ont pu repartir avec des
retard de 10 à 15 minutes environ la
SNCF assure que le trafic devrait
reprendre son cours progressivement on
travaille sur la voie qui a été
perturbée je pense qu'on pourra faire
une réparation provisoire qui s'achèvera
je pense en début d'après-midi ce qui
nous permettra d'assurer un trafic quasi
normal pour la pointe de soirée et
ensuite on fera une réparation
définitive dans la nuit qui nous
permettra d'avoir à nouveau la plinitude
de nos installations demain matin les
lignes de transignen Neu ont également
été perturbées sur les quais les
voyageurs ont été informés très tôt de
la situation et la SNCF a distribué aux
usagers restés bloqués ce mot d'excuse
pour justifier le retard des
salariés ce 78 est maintenant terminé
merci de votre attention demain vendredi
vous avez rendez-vous avec le 78 weekend
présenté par Alice gasting qui recevra
notamment des responsables de
l'association des Amis du passé
d'éencour pour parler des vendanges qui
ont lieu à hencour ce dimanche bonne
soirée à vous et à très
[Musique]
bientôt